Huawei's chief financial officer was granted
bail of ten million dollars after three days
of hearings in Vancouver. Meng Wanzhou will
have to turn over her passports, wear an ankel
bracelet, and she will confined at night to
her home in Vancouver.
Meng is a often viewed as a national heroine
in China, so her release after over a week
in detentionwas a relief to many in Beijing.
I feel happy. It`s a victory for the national
enterprise. Although it`s only a bail, I still
hope all the sanctions on Huawei could be
cancelled. It is important that we have fair
international competition. Sanctions only
on China is not fairness.
Still, the prospect of the Meng being used
as a bargaining chip in trade negotiations
between China and the US increased, as US
president Trump said he would intervene in
the case if it was in America's interest.
Hours before the bail hearing, a former Canadian
diplomat was arrested in Beijing, presumably
in retaliation for Meng's arrest. Canada's
government is still collecting details.
We are aware of the situation of the Canadian
detained in China. We have been in direct
contact with the Chinese, Chinese diplomats
and representatives. We are engaged on the
file which we take very seriously and we are
of course providing consular assistance to
the family.
Markets in Asia closed higher after Meng was
released, as investors' eased their fears
about the trade battle among the world's two
top economies.